we can fan the Flames of division and
hatred that are roiling the world here's
the president of Harvard Claudine gay
and here she is explaining why these
protests should be allowed now now try
to imagine if these protests were Maga
protests try to imagine if these
protests were I don't know against
vaccines or against mandates what she
would be saying try to imagine if these
protests were I don't know a bunch of
girls who didn't want dudes with dicks
swimming against
them and now listen to the utter
hypocrisy of This Woman This is a moment
of intense pain and grief for a great
many people in our community and around
the world I feel that pain and grief
myself as members of a university
community we have a
choice we can fan the Flames of division
and hatred that are roiling the
world or we can try to be a force for
something different and
better people have asked me where we
stand so let me be
clear our University rejects terrorism
that includes the barbaric atrocities
perpetrated by
Hamas our University rejects hate hate
of Jews hate of Muslims hate of any
group of people based on their faith
their national origin or any aspect of
their
identity our University rejects the
harassment or intim ation of individuals
based on their
beliefs and our University Embraces a
commitment to free
expression that commitment extends even
to views that many of us find
objectionable even
outrageous we do not punish or sanction
people for expressing such
views we should have put a laugh track
in that for every dishonest thing that
she said she doesn't give a sh about
free speech anything else they gladly
would have kicked people out of the
school and did for not abiding by their
vaccine policies or mandates again I I
Illustrated several examples of things
that she would never be supporting right
a magga group shows up at campus you
think she'd be giving that talk girls
who want to swim with girls group shows
up and that's not a lesbian joke that's
just girls used to swim with girls
that's how they'd race everything they
say is aive but James Lindsay you guys
know James Lindsay I've had him on the
show many times James is one of the
clearest thinkers literally in the world
I think when it comes to let's get James
on next week by the way and by also we
are going to continue doing this thing
where we have guests join us in the
middle of the show I think we're doing
it every day this week except for today
uh but James Lindsay um has been
exposing how how evil the woke thing is
and how it how it basically uses all of
our strengths and turns them into
weaknesses so he saw that video uh by
the Harvard president he wrote this
Communists only appeal to your values
when they're losing and or manipulating
you with them and that is ex exactly
what she's doing there she does not care
about Free Speech she doesn't care if
kids are intimidated imagine if you were
just the average Jewish kid you don't
have to be Israeli you're a Jewish kid
or or you're just like a pro-america kid
and these rallies are going by your dorm
room and everyone's screaming and
everything else and from the river to
the SE and you're just like I don't
really want to be involved in that guess
what you're going on a list with these
people too you really
are